Bob kandata Seattle Times Seahawks
reporter joining us try to explain what
the heck happened with Colin Kaepernick
so Bob what do we know about this
meeting and what one side is saying and
what the other side is saying well
you're right yeah there are sort of two
sides here
the Kaepernick side is that it was that
the Seahawks just flat-out asked him
about whether he would continue to kneel
for the anthem or whether he would stand
and that he and that when he said he
didn't know that they scuttled the
meeting that they were they were going
to have with him on Monday the the
Seahawk side is a little bit more
nuanced that they basically just wanted
to know what his plan was and that he
and he didn't tell them one way or the
other what he was going to do and that
it and that I think their side is that
it was also a little bit broader than
that just kind of everything you know
what are sort of your plans in general
if we sign you you know how much is
football and how much is everything else
that you're sort of involved in and that
you didn't really have a have a clear
plan for them I was their side of it
anyway I think exactly what he could
tell them that he would do and so I you
know their their their view of it is
that they didn't cancel the meeting they
weren't done with him they were they
were just going to post postpone it that
they wanted to kind of get together and
make sure they understood what they
would be getting into if they were but
why is anybody surprised with what Colin
Kaepernick his his stance for lack of a
better expression is and you know is
Seattle weeding out the the bigger
personalities or is that just a
coincidence Bob that you have Bennett
and you have Sherman who were no longer
with the team well yeah that's sort of
two different things
the one thing and again the shock review
is Kaepernick didn't tell them one way
or the other
so I think they wanted to know so I
think they wanted to know are you gonna
kneel or are you gonna stand and then we
know so I don't think they wanted to be
surprised one way or the other like we
sign him and then the first game nobody
knows what he's gonna do and that
becomes the storyline I think they
wanted to know one way or the other I
think I think they were caught off guard
when both Jeremy Lane and Michael Bennet
that's for the anthem the first time
they didn't know either time that that
was going to happen and you know so Pete
Carroll's press conferences after the
game became basically solely about that
I don't think they wanted bad this time
I think they wanted to
not have not be tailored not be caught
off guard by anything that would happen
so I think that's where the fact that
Kaepernick wouldn't tell them apparently
one way or the other what he was going
to do became an issue in terms of
weeding out I do think there's a little
bit of I don't think it's for social
activism necessarily as much as just
there I think there wasn't an aspect of
thinking that obviously they didn't you
know they didn't have the year last year
they've had they'd had the previous five
they didn't make playoffs and you know
got hammered by that by the rams late in
the season that had some other losses
that were sort of surprising in the way
they happen and so I think they did feel
like there was maybe a need to kind of
just turn over the team a little bit you
know both both Furman and Bennett you
can totally defend them on just football
aspects I mean Sherman has an injury
nobody knows for sure how he's going to
come off of that I there's probably not
any team really there was me I mean the
49ers didn't sign him to a huge
guaranteed contract
you know they signed him to sort of a
one-year prove a thing as well you know
that the Seahawks that's you know that's
what they told Sherman also as they
didn't really want to read up him to a
long-term deal right now given that and
then Bennett will be 33 and has had knee
injuries the last couple years and I
think they felt this play had slipped a
little bit last year also but certainly
you know you can look at those and view
it as the the leadership in the locker
room is going to be quite a bit
different going forward as well what's
the local reaction though in Seattle
with these fans of bringing in
Kaepernick I know it's pretty liberal
liberal with your owner and and your
coach how's the rest of the city do you
think as a whole feel about this well
it's interesting because if you set
aside the mainly for the anthem and
everything in Kaepernick obviously was
was sort of with sort of enemy number
one for a few years anyway because he
was the quarterback of the 49ers and and
you know they had so many memorable
games against them and obviously that
the biggest play in Seahawks history
Kaepernick was part of you know the
Richard Sherman's hits interception that
they clinched the 2013 NFC title game so
I think there's some people just some a
football standpoint you know it's sort
of like he was kind of the enemy but
it's also intriguing because you did see
this guy play really well against the
Seahawks a few times also but you're
right you know from just a city
standpoint I mean if there's a you know
there wasn't really any blowback to I
I mean Michael Bennett sat for the
anthem for all the two games last year
most of the defensive line also sat
along with him sort of in solidarity to
that you know I I don't think there was
a whole lot of blow-by-blow back from
that people weren't booing Michael
Bennett all over the place or anything
like that I think people were going to
be more than accepting of Kaepernick
from that standpoint do you think
there's still chance Kaepernick's on
this Seahawks roster I don't know I mean
it was interesting today you wake up and
they signed a guy named Steven Morris
who I think is hardly going to be the
last thing that the Seahawks do from a
backup quarterback standpoint you know I
would say I
the Seahawks probably could have done
without this becoming public when it did
I think they were hoping that this
probably could have stayed behind the
scenes while they well they felt while
they decided if they were still wanted
to bring him in for a visit but maybe
Kaepernick felt like that wasn't going
to happen anyway and so they felt like
they didn't matter to matter if it if
they if they kind of let this out but
you know I think it's pretty obvious
that this was sort of leaked by the
Kaepernick side and then the Seahawks
were sort of in reaction mode to it good
stuff Bob thanks for joining us we
appreciate your time all right thank you
Bob candana Seattle Times Seahawks
reporter for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]